[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la campagne du plastique continue cette
offensive en disant monsieur andré
malraux a fait la plus pitoyable des
victimes une fillette de 5 ans qui a
failli perdre la vie la liste des
explosions salon l'ouest comprendre
appelle la criminelle folie de ces
méthodes aveugle qui heurte toutes les
consciences
passant outre à l'interdiction de toute
manifestation
formulées et réitérée par le
gouvernement certains partis et
groupements voulu manifester à la
bastille contre l'action de l'oas des
forces policières nombreuses avaient été
massées pour faire respecter la décision
du gouvernement et de sérieuses
échauffourées se déroulèrent entre
services d'ordre des manifestants
laissant le triste bilan de 8 morts et
250 blessés
[Musique]
louisenthal est aujourd'hui le nom d'un
drame un drame qui avec ses quelques 300
morts rappelle tragiquement les
souvenirs de marcinelle et de courrières
dès l'annoncé de la catastrophe
la population entière de louisenthal ses
portes et aux abords de la mine chacun
guettant la sortie des survivants pour
les interroger ou cherchant dans les
listes sans cesse renouvelée la
confirmation de son espoir ou de son
malheur et la gravité des blessures de
certains mineurs peut aggraver le triste
bilan
assez mort de la mine la mine a fait les
obsèques les plus émouvantes au 286
cercueils alignés sur dix rangs derrière
le carreau de la mine
la population sarroise les délégations
de mineurs venus de france de belgique
et du luxembourg et le président de la
république fédérale allemande monsieur
luc et sont venus rendre un hommage
solennel et déchirant c'est le deuil
d'un village le deuil d'une nation et
plus même le deuil d'un métier dur et
dangereux saluons ici les morts de
louisiane tard
mais très longues heures à température
de zéro degré de l'étalon international
platini riez déposé au pavillon de
breteuil à sèvres eh bien oui pour des
générations d'écoliers le pavillon de
breteuil demeurait le mystérieux repères
du maître étalon on ne sortait pas
souvent mais ce m a fait son temps il
offrait une précision de l'ordre du dix
millième de millimètre précision
dérisoire il nous la faut aujourd'hui au
millième de micron et c'est pourquoi
sans même le savoir la mercière a changé
de m depuis janvier dernier le journal
officiel est formel le maître de papa
est mort
messieurs terrien et un nom au pavillon
de breteuil ont mis au point la nouvelle
définition désormais légal qui doit
remplacer notre maître à la hauteur des
précision exigée par les sciences
d'aujourd'hui du même coup sa mesure
exige à partir d'une lente à christian
86 un appareillage d'une complexité
saisissant sachons simplement qu'il faut
un comparateur interférences y ait là
microscope photo électrique combinée à
l'interféromètre de mickelson
titres électroniques
caissons étanches et calorifuge et où le
comparateur est enfermé
[Musique]
sans oublier surtout une dalle de béton
de 30 tonnes montés sur un amortisseur
qui assure une parfaite stabilité à
l'appareil
mais tout cet appareillage te sembler
relativement simple eu égard à la
définition elle même le m la longueur
égale à 1 milliard qui s'ancre à
poussettes fassois femmes 3073 longueur
tombe dans le vide de la femme gaie
correspondant à la transition entre les
niveaux 2 publie ses flingues de 5 de
l'atome décryptant 80 comme c'est simple
et c'est justement à cette heure que la
grande-bretagne mélancoliquement parle
de se rallier au système métrique car
outre la tristesse inhérentes à
l'abandon de ces chaires vieille chose
qui était le yard l'on sait le gallon il
lui faudra payer la transformation de
toutes ces machines à compter à calculer
a enregistré à additionner a
comptabilisé des centaines de milliers
de machines
à perfide albion pourquoi n'avoir pas
accepté tout de suite voici un siècle et
demi ce pauvre m de papa qui n'était
alors tout bêtement que la dix
millionième partie du quart du méridien
terrestre ou à peu près
[Musique]
jeux mondiaux championnats du monde de
ski on ne sait pas exactement ce que
c'est depuis que chancellerie s'en sont
mêlés quoi qu'il en soit pour une
semaine chamonix et la capitale
incontestée du ski alpin et c'est par
une mise en scène à grand spectacle que
débute cette semaine internationale des
sports de neige comme s'il s'agissait de
vrais championnats du monde
le rideau est levé
[Musique]
la jeune génération la classe biberon ce
ne sont pas seulement les fans de johnny
hallyday ni les plus excités qui
sautille en choeur au son du twist dans
les salles enfumées la classe biberon
c'est aussi cela
le grand champion c'est une petite fille
elle a un peu plus de 16
[Musique]
sa joie à elle c'est de prendre des
risques de foncer sur une piste de ski
là au moins en bagarre on se bat avec
soi même c'est dur de s'entraîner pour
en arriver là et l'on se bat aussi
contre les autres championnes qui sont
là également pour gagner
[Musique]
la petite marielle goitschel fait tout
ce qu'elle peut pour gagner
elle a la technique la maîtrise c'est
déjà un grand monsieur
[Musique]
elle ne va pas gagner elle termine
quatrième du slalom géant à trois
dixièmes de seconde seulement de la
première
le temps d'une larme ou d'un battement
de cils
plus heureuse qu'elle l'autrichienne
eric ané terre secondes de l'épreuve et
la gagnante sa compatriote maria miam
messieurs les anglais tirez les premiers
on ne leur a pas dit deux fois au cours
du match angleterre irlande à twickenham
match comptant pour le tournoi des six
nations trois minutes à peine après le
commencement de la rencontre les anglais
marquent en effet un essai entre les
poteaux
à peine interrompue par une mêlée
l'offensive repart et ce sont toujours
les anglais en maillot blanc qui tirent
les premiers
tiens tiens ça leur rappelle des
souvenirs assez marrant et voici le
grand maître à jouer richardson en
pleine action ce n'est pas un homme
c'est une fuse
et là les anglais s'amusent comme des
petits fous
il est vrai que les irlandais ne ferme
pas le jeu ils ont attaqué de temps en
temps mais contre des adversaires aussi
a droit aussi rapide et aussi puissante
et anglais il n'y a rien à faire cette
nouvelle envolée des héritiers de
l'eisti
remarquez bien qu'on ne se fait pas de
cadeau pour s'emparer du ballon
voici le point final de cette rencontre
nouvel essai pour les anglais qui gagne
ce match par 16 à 0 de quoi donner des
frissons à l'équipe de france qui
rencontre bientôt l'angleterre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous on voyage historique la première
traversée de la transatlantique est
toujours historique le paquebot france à
voguer à 32 noeuds de moyenne sur une
mer agitée une mer agitée qui n'a pas
empêché les quelques 17 cents passagers
d'apprécier les plaisirs du corps
c'est ainsi que les invités du président
de la transat lesieu anduze paris et du
commandant croisille ont partagé avec
juliette gréco et marcel achard le
gâteau monumental orné d'une réplique du
paquebot dont on apprécia sans doute
qu'il soit le plus long du monde
pour les générations qui n'ont pas
encore passé le cap des dix ans guignent
à l'offre est un spectacle permanent
[Musique]
quant aux autres que guignol ne
passionne plus ils ont trouvé en
juliette gréco imparfait professeur de
twist et le twist fit rage sur le france
ainsi passèrent cinq jours au bout
desquels se profile à la statue de la
liberté et lefranc pénétrer dans
l'essonne river survolé par les
hélicoptères saluée par les bateaux
pompes et le mugissement des sirènes
d'un grand port
au pied des gratte ciel de manhattan new
york lui a fait l'accueil grandiose
qu'il réserve à voici bientôt 30 ans au
normandie
[Musique]
à ces huit victimes paris a fait les
funérailles les plus éloquentes de la
bourse du travail où les cercueils
avaient été exposées avait reçu un
premier hommage jusqu'au cimetière du
père lachaise une foule immense dont le
nombre peut s'évaluer à plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes a
suivi le cortège
cortège silencieux seulement ponctué des
accents d'une marche funèbre et dont nul
cris lui l'incident n'a troublé le
déroulement
des monceaux de fleurs gerbes coûteuse
web le bouquet en donnait le ton de la
piété populaire
ce cortège funèbre qu'on évalue à 150
milles ou à un million de présence avait
la valeur d'une affirmation solennelle
il ne faut plus que la paix intérieure
soit troublé
[Musique]
père lachaise la même foule le même
silence la tristesse des familles
éprouvées une fleur qu'on jette sur un
cercueil une femme évanouie qu'on
emporte et par dessus tout la conscience
d'un peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]